[Music]
today's question comes from travis in
wisconsin i'm having a moral dilemma
regarding the job change i work as a
truck driver my current employer treats
me very well
the until recently the company covered
10 states with four drivers and 10
people in support positions the driving
staff is now
down to two people me and one other
driver a company that shares our
building complex has been recruiting
drivers and they approached me and
offered me a position that is 25 more
than i currently make i'd be home every
night and it offers a better 401k it
would obviously be a good move for me
but it would
[ __ ] my current employer to the point
where they may go out of business i have
to think about what is best for myself
but my decision will most likely
directly impact
11 other families at the same time what
is the right decision to make well
travis
the right decision is to do what is best
for you this is a very tough emotional
situation i get this call a lot dave
on the ken coleman show where people go
i love the people that i'm with they've
been good to me
but i know it's time for me to move on
i'm moving on to something that i know
is on purpose yada yada but if i leave
i feel like it's going to hurt the
company and and what i have said not to
be glib and not to be insensitive but if
this man travis leaving this company
uh
will cause this company to go out of
business then they were going to go out
of business with him anyway
one person while it may do some harm
the company's got bigger issues than
whether travis is there they've already
been whittled down to the point where
it's just travis and somebody else so
going down with the ship here that's the
the old school metaphor is not honorable
it doesn't make sense you have to do
what is right for you and your family
this is an absolute no-brainer uh do
your best to transition out uh the
classy way but yeah you got to do what's
right for you it's not your problem that
the company has been crippled yeah
um but he's a good dude and i understand
the heart behind he's got a great heart
of loyalty but um
if if you stay if you
leaving causes them to go out of
business they're going to go out of
business if you stay without question
they're not going to if they're down to
one driver being there or not being
there causes them to go out of business
it's too late it's over
so you don't you can't carry that
responsibility or that guilt because
it's not accurate
okay it's um yeah does it put them in a
hurt and are you kicking them when
they're down yeah a little bit and i
appreciate the the the that bothers you
that means you're a good person
so here's what i would do
um to try to
you know to try to uh i guess
offset that a little bit i would go to
your future employer
and say i'm not going to be able to come
for a little while what's the latest
start date you can give me because i
really don't want to mess these guys
over over here i want to i want to try
to help them make the transition and i
need to give them a super long notice
can you wait one month for me to come
instead of just two weeks
and by the way you you want me to come
because i'm the kind of guy that acts
this way so i'll act this way towards
you when i'm here i'm not gonna mess you
over
so you know you don't want to hire
people that are going to cut your throat
and i don't like cutting my old guy's
throat over here i appreciate the offer
what's the latest start date you can
give me and if it gives you four weeks
out instead of two weeks out then you go
back into your current employer and you
say hey listen here's what i've
negotiated i can leave tomorrow or i can
leave in four weeks if you'll increase
my pay while i'm here i'll stay four
weeks so you can get time to get some
drivers on and you get in a bl you know
you get in a hardcore recruiting mode
and get you some drivers in here
and because i love you guys and i don't
want to leave you in a lurch and so i've
negotiated it this way i am leaving
now
or two weeks or four weeks your choice
you need to give me a raise to stay
during that four weeks while you go get
drivers
and that's not unfair that's very
reasonable
and you know if you did that with me
um i'm probably going to go ahead and
set you free even if it hurts not
because i'm mad at you but just because
i've got a saying around ramsay have
since i started this place when your
spirit leaves you should take your butt
with it
and uh because people stay sticking
around at a place where they're no
longer care no longer plugged in
they're they're they have their eyes on
the future they've already moved on uh
it's it's very difficult to not say
negative things it's very difficult to
uh not roll your eyes it's very
difficult to
you know bring it you mail it in instead
and all of that so people working on a
two-week notice around here we do it a
little bit we'll do three days or four
days to get stuff transitioned but uh we
accept the two-week notice and that's a
classy thing to offer it but seldom do
we work them out at ramsey we just when
your butt leaves y'all take your spirit
with it so but you go in and talk to
those two guys and treat them like men
and women and grown-ups and you be a
grown-up and i think you'll find a way
to do this with great honor because
you're a man of honor